here now with more house well maybe soon
to be speaker of the house uh House
minority leader Kevin McCarthy I think
that might be the last time I introduce
you is that uh thank you for being with
us congratulations on what is a huge
victory for the American people because
this is the this is the only Avenue in
government now that we'll be able to put
a check and a balance on the Biden
Administration and these new green Deal
Democrats uh let's first talk about you
won the nomination inside your party
caucus you have to get 218 votes to be
the speaker of the house there's a small
margin will the Republicans put their
egos aside will they work together will
they follow up on their commitments to
America will they use the power of
subpoena and the power of the purse
I believe so Sean and we need to work
together because you are right we are
the only Republican entity that can stop
this disastrous Biden agenda think for
one moment it is official one party
Democrat rule in Washington is finished
we have fired Nancy Pelosi we have
worked hard to earn this agenda you were
right that we worked very hard on
getting this majority but we put the
commitment to America out there we told
the American public exactly what would
we do and think about it the 218th seat
that was called tonight
was Congressman Mike Garcia a former
Naval Academy F-18 pilot this is Los
Angeles County this is a seat that Joe
Biden carried by 13 points and we won it
and we still got more good news tonight
Madera just came back in the count for
California 13th and John Duarte had just
gone up by 900 votes so we've got about
four more seats out there possibly that
we can win but the one thing I know in
Washington they don't hand the gavels
out in small medium and large size
that's one size gavel with the ability
to subpoena and hold this government
accountable secure this border fight to
make us energy independent give a
parents a say in their kids education
and actually look what the doj is doing
what the DHS is doing in others and
that's exactly what we're going to do on
day one in this house we will repeal
eighty seven thousand new IRA address
agents
now you would have the power to do that
wouldn't you because you have the power
of the purse
that's exactly right and we will use the
power of the purse the size of our debt
has got to stop but we've got to
actually focus in what we actually what
we did listening to the American public
you've got to make an economy that's
strong they're hurting because of
inflation we've got to cut back on this
wasteful Washington spending we've got
to make ourselves energy independent and
Not Just Energy independent Let's help
our allies let's make China dependent on
our natural gas let's secure our border
so our children are no longer being
killed by fentanyl every single day
let's make sure we stop defunding the
police and start funding them let's make
sure parents have a parent's Bill of
Rights of say in their kids education
let's make sure government is held
accountable you've got two congressmen
coming up here shortly they're going to
lead the charge are making sure
government is held accountable
now I know we have what Congressman
Comer coming up and uh he is on the
house oversight committee he says he's
ready to subpoena Hunter Biden uh Jim
Jordan is now uh going to be looking
into whether or not the FBI has been
politicized the doj has been weaponized
uh that's an important investigation
well we also have investigations into
the NIH the possible of funding through
the eco-alliance of the Wuhan virology
lab in other words did American
taxpayers help pay for covid-19 will
that be part of the investigative
yeah we've already begun we want to know
the origins of where covid began so we
never have that happen again who funded
it how did it get there we want to know
what happened in the last 60 days of
Afghanistan why didn't the president
listen to the military creating 13 new
gold star families that never should
have taken place we've got a number of
ways why did the doj go after parents
and call them terrorists how can we have
a Secretary of Homeland calling that
this border is secure when you have more
than 2.7 individuals illegally coming
across are the number of people on the
terrorist watch list coming into America
what do they have planned who are they
talking to and why are they here
that's just a start
let me ask you this question and it has
to do and and we saw the power that
Nancy Pelosi had with the similar uh of
majority same size majority that is she
yes
okay so my question to you is this and I
know everybody has their own agenda but
there are a lot of 80 20 issues 70 30
issues 90 10 issues and uh look I don't
know what's going to happen within the
caucus but any four congressmen can
cause an awful lot of trouble if you're
the speaker of the house or in the
process of becoming speaker the only
admonition I have to the Republicans if
they don't work as a unit they're not
going to succeed you're going to live
and die together and I think if you stay
on those issues are you confident that
the caucus will hold strong together and
rally around the issues that the
American people entrusted you with when
you made your commitments to America
Sean we work together on this commitment
to America everybody in the caucus
worked for the last year and a half and
you watched him to put it out to make an
economy that's strong a nation that's
safe a future that's built on freedom
and a government's held accountable we
just had what you would think is a is a
primary with more than 84 percent of the
conference I was able to win we had that
debate now is the time to move forward
you're correct to really save this
nation to work for the American people
we have to work as a team or we'll lose
as individuals and I believe this
conference will rally together because
we will have a tough time but if we
listen and work harder together we can
make the next Century the American
Century we are the only ones holding
against this disastrous agenda by Joe
Biden but think for one moment four
years ago I was elected leader we had
just lost the majority less than 200
seats and for the last two election
Cycles we have done nothing but win
seats the Republicans in the Senate lost
the Republic Republicans in the
governor's lost but it's only been the
house we are the last line of defense so
we can't take this personal we can't go
out and make our own individual ideas we
need to work at the team for the sake of
this nation and I ask anybody to join
with us and you look at this new
Freshman Class you look at this
Republican party we will listen to the
American public but we will lead for the
American public as well join with us
because we'll work with anyone that
wants to make America better
Kevin McCarthy Congressman thank you for
being with us congratulations again hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else